focus on the few not the many  focus on the meaning of the menu meaning  uh most of the kids or most of the  adults have got four or five projects  none of which are worth the [ __ ]  okay and so they're they're trying to uh  make them all work because they're  afraid to walk away because they spent  too much time developing it the great  thing about the internet is the results  are instantaneous yet kids work on apps  and programs uh and write code  not for an hour a week a month but years  and they get no results  your results are instantaneous most most  of the programs don't work so focus on  the few not the many laser beam focus  and absolute a thousand percent total  commitment and willing to make personal  sacrifice